all right so again the the basic idea
here is that january 6th is an excuse
for everything that we want to do ever
and forever
right because republicans are fonts of
misinformation therefore we have to have
social media shutting them down i mean
representative promise i paul by the way
she says that this should become a thing
that twitter and facebook should just
shut down anyone who disagrees with her
because again threat to democracy right
it's always it's always some deep threat
that requires basic freedoms to be
curbed
it's no secret that our social media
companies have been part of their
algorithms promoting disinformation and
i think that these steps are important
but frankly a little too little and a
little too late
the reality is it's not just marjorie
taylor green all over twitter social
media facebook uh all of these companies
have been using algorithms that are just
about clickbait not about truth and so
if we are
going to
take on the disinformation that's out
there the big lie and everything else
that goes with it then yes this is a
part of it but it's got to be much much
more we we have to crack down on the
first amendment in order to save the
first amendment we have to crack down on
your ability to to vote with a certain
amount of certainty
in order to save
voting right
it's amazing how often they use this
logic
in fact we have to we have to curb all
of the traditional institutions of
american democracy in order to save
american democracy according to
professor jedediah britton purdy a
professor of constitutional law at
columbia
he has a piece in the new york times
called the republican party is
succeeding because we are not a true
democracy oh so when you win it's a
democracy and when you lose it's not a
true democracy i kind of see how this is
working
the january 6th attack would not have
happened in a genuine democracy
says uh britain purdy
really because i feel like uh the the
entire summer of 2020 before trump
and january 6. before any of that
happened
attacks on federal courthouses in
portland massive riots across the united
states like dozens if not hundreds of
riots across the united states
like it wouldn't have happened
so you explained to me when exactly was
there a genuine democracy in the united
states and and no violence involved ever
i mean what was that period exactly
says professor britton perry the attack
was the most acute symptom of the
political crisis that donald trump
incited by refusing to admit defeat in
the 2020 election but the roots of the
crisis run deep into the undemocratic
features of our constitutional system
at a basic level today's republican
party succeeds only because the
electoral college the senate and the
supreme court all tilt in its favor that
system has handed conservatives a 6-3
majority on the supreme court despite
the fact that only one republican has
won the presidential popular vote after
1988. a party doesn't have to persuade
majorities it has the best vision for
the country it only has to persuade a
selective minority that the other side
is immortal threat its grasp on power
may be too tenuous for the party to
govern effectively but it has offered
conservatives a fine perch to weaken
economic and environmental regulation
appoint conservative judges and launch
attacks on the democratic system itself
in a more democratic system says this
professor of constitutional law the
republican party's extreme elements
would have been sent packing long before
they stormed the capitol because they
couldn't muster enough votes to win a
national election instead they have
perfected minority rule as a path to
political success an anti-democratic
system has bred an anti-democratic party
the remedy is to democratize our
so-called democracy yes pure
majoritarianism
what the founders call mob rule will
certainly make things much better
because when the mob rules nothing bad
ever happens when you have just a pure
majority cramming down its opinions on
the minority without without any sort of
of hampering mechanisms
then only good comes from that as we
know from none of world history ever
that this is the this is the basic idea
for the democrats if we just go to pure
majoritarianism then it'll be good by
the way if they start to lose in a pure
majoritarian state like let's say that
the next republican presidential
candidate in 2024 wins a popular vote
then we'll be back to well what what
systems are broken here that could have
allowed this to possibly happen
okay again january 6th is all about
exploitation it was never about january
6th purely
and that is the problem if it had been
just about january 6 we all would have
agreed if it's about the exploitation
then we all ought to not agree because
it is really really
kind of gross to use a a
horrible riot on january 6th
not nearly as horrible in terms of
property damage or loss of life is
anything that happened in 2020 by the
way
but a horrible image for the united
states to use that as an excuse to
batter away traditional institutions
like the filibuster as well as the state
control over voting rights in order to
shore up your chances in 2022 that seems
like much more of a threat to democracy
than 200 drugs invading the capitol
building getting themselves arrested and
thrown in jail
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe